well the 2022 billboard music awards
have arrived to las vegas we have our
sparkly mic the gray carpet has been
laid out the stars are here we're
bringing you all the coverage and so
tonight
we're going to celebrate like we got a
second chance at life up in here and
we're going to celebrate a chance to be
able to do it better and do it bigger
and celebrate each other from incredible
performances to exciting awards and a
first-time host diddy's hosting first of
all so you already know if you don't
know like a ditty party
man it's about to go crazy up in here
the whole family showed up to support
diddy i'm so so so so i could say 10
more so's but so excited he's been
practicing for this for so long and we
can't wait to see it on the stage
tonight the show is going to be wicked
award shows in vegas mean our local
headliners show up i've always loved las
vegas beautiful people great place to
raise your kids and a lot of fun to have
a little residency well we're so happy
to have you here you can just give a
little wave i love you guys so much i
can't wait to come back and see again
you're a las vegas local you're one of
us yeah yeah definitely i mean i usually
don't go out until the sun go down but
today i make an exception for puff some
of the big winners of the night include
olivia rodrigo for best female artist
drake for top billboard artist and we
caught up with the billboard music award
winner for best dance electronic album
you're nominated for best dance
electronic album how does that feel i
mean you just keep topping the charts
and you're always doing something it's
been it's been fun so i'm just glad it
you know relates with my fans and and
you know that's who i love the most so
i'm just happy to be here the nominees
and the performers were bringing big
energy to the mgm stage you are
performing tonight here with billboards
what can we expect to see
a lot of big energy i told him i'm
performing like this new version of big
energy so it feels fresh and fun
and y'all better be look y'all in for a
treat i hope y'all ready
count of three
[Music]
[Music]
make
ain't too many of them
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]